everyone travels here at blizzcon 2014
i'm joined by alan dabiri it was the
lead software engineer on heroes of the
storm thanks for joining me I actually
had a chance to talk to Chris szigeti
last year and now feels like the game
has changed so much during that time and
you guys just recently announced closed
beta first question is what is the
difference between a closed alpha and a
closed beta for you guys because I mean
at the other day might feel a little
semi right yeah for us the reason why we
call the initial phase of technical
alpha its technical sorry yeah we really
wanted to kind of emphasize that we're
still building the game with feeling it
out we're testing out our server
infrastructure we're really trying to
see all the elements that we need to put
in to support this game now that we're
heading into closed beta we feel like
we've got the base game figured out
we've got our base level of the heroes
that we're going to have the
battlegrounds we've also got a lot of
our features doesn't mean the game is
done there's still a lot more that we're
going to add to the game but we're much
farther along than where we were when we
started the technical alpha along those
lines we're starting to see you guys pit
and a lot of the systems like the ranks
play you're talking about a little bit
in the panel today about the lever
system that you guys are sort of
exploring uh you know there are other
games that I know you guys don't like
the the MOBA term but there's other
games out there similar to hero brawlers
right and I'm just curious how much you
have looked at those existing games for
you know maybe inspiration on the
systems that you guys have since I think
that this kind of genre has like a very
unique style of things that you have to
deal with in terms of the social aspects
yeah definitely know we've we've played
all those games I mean we're huge fans
of the genre and so we've played a lot
of these games we've looked into the way
that other people have dealt with this
both in the genre and outside the genre
some of those things we've we've thought
about we've explored right now we're
going for a couple of different takes
weiming the biggest thing for us is just
the game design itself we feel lends
itself towards a different play
experience but we'll also explore some
of those make game features that would
try to combat some of the more
our community elements of the game that
where people who are toxic might cause
you know other players to not have as
much fun yeah for the lever system for
instance you started to talk a little
bit about that I know you haven't really
given too many details and sounds like
that's still being in developed but when
you look at that do you do you see any
issue where maybe like if you encourage
people to to stay in the game long
enough for her to you discourage leavers
enough that there's not that many that
like the queues for these games are
going to get really long for them it
might discourage them from continuing to
play the game do you mean if levers then
have no other levers to get yeah exactly
right it could extend the queue times
right so just to explain a little bit
about what that system is basically
we're talking about if you leave a game
we will match you up with other levers
to play together on your team it doesn't
actually mean that will match you up
against other levers for the opposing
team ok so you don't technically need a
full ten players it might just be fill
out the rest of your team with other
levers at the end of the day though if
we if it truly was such a small number
that they had a hard time getting of the
games i actually think we've won okay
and those few players that couldn't make
it into a game unfortunately they're the
outliers yeah so does that mean that
maybe the the team that goes up against
a team that doesn't have a bunch of
levers on it they're like we got the
leaver team guys it's going to be an
easy way I'm not sure that we're gonna
like call that out to AO that it's a
leader team but when you start to see
two or three guys leave you're like oh
it's one of those if they continue along
with that style of play then yeah you'll
know when people are just leaving a game
either that either you think you're
doing awesome or there are a team of
leaders yeah now whenever I talk to
Chris last year there's a little bit
discussion around a competitive eSports
stuff and obviously you guys are a
company that has a heritage of these
eSports titles at the time you said well
you know we're still kind of figuring
out how the community will approach the
game and if they're interested in it but
here you guys are holding a tournament
lots of notable past eSports players
participating where are you guys at in
terms of you know feeling about the game
in terms of an eSports title or maybe a
competitive title sure at the end of the
day like we're going to support this
game in however the community wants so I
think that's what Chris was speaking to
previously when you talk to him is that
if a lot of our games from an eSports
perspective they've developed or gay
the community has shown us that hey we
really want this to be any sport so for
Heroes it's kind of the same thing where
we're waiting to kind of see a little
bit how this works out but at the same
time we've already started seeing that
even though we're in technical alpha the
game's not done we don't even have
everyone playing the game yet we already
see teams forming around it tournaments
starting to you know be played and so
we're trying to embrace that and support
that as much as possible the invitation
on the exhibition games we have here are
kind of an example of that we added
custom games back in we added the
initial observer mode to kind of support
this so that we can kind of see where
this goes at the same time we're also
discussing internally what we're going
to do for east boards for heroes of the
storm and we're definitely going to
support it ok very good so yeah as you
see this stuff happen as you create the
Invitational here and you have this how
does that inform you know where you you
put resources maybe four features or
that kind of thing yeah i mean the
esports guys and girls are always
talking to us about hey we could really
use this or that i mean some of our
motivations of putting the initial
observer mode and custom games back in
the game was purely because esports was
saying look people are chomping at the
bit right now they want to get get this
in as a tournament and so we threw it
back in so we're just like in starcraft
we embrace these words we love you
sports and a lot of features we put into
starcraft we're solely just for eSports
we're probably going to do the same
thing with heroes and support it in any
way we can in terms of the free-to-play
sort of like market features and in-game
cus purchasable items and different
things you guys doing with skins and all
that how do you feel about the current
model that you guys have is it is it are
you guys pretty comfortable with as that
something that we should see or expect
to see continued into closed beta and
beyond yeah i think i think the model is
working for us we're still exploring it
it's still early so this is a technical
alpha we haven't invited everyone in yet
but for the most part we're actually
very happy with the direction it's going
we feel that there's an easy way for you
to jump in and play a good amount of
this game we've got the hero rotation
depending on what level you get to
you'll be able to unlock basically play
for free seven heroes every week so
there's a there's a good amount of game
that you can get without actually paying
any money to us at all and then over
time as you learn the game and you want
to kind of keep playing some of those
heroes you can purchase them purchase
skins things like that so this is kind
of a maybe broader question about the
company but I'm really happy to ask you
this question because it kind of ties
into heroes of the storm you guys have
now just announced a new game at
blizzard ever you know I used to play
wow way back Warcraft etc during that
time you guys have gone from a company
that you know has maybe one title that
you've announced for development to now
you have all these different things many
games that are continuing to be
developed even after launch what is it
like because heroes is kind of you know
not to make the pun but the Nexus of
this idea of all these different titles
and games and that kind of thing what is
it like to be working on this project
that is tied into all the stuff that's
continuing to grow I mean we just saw
overwatch today yeah it's it's awesome
and I know if you talk to the artist
they'll tell you it's even more awesome
because they get to actually touch all
the different universes they get to
bring in those the the characters the
heroes the villains that you're so used
to from all the different games and
bring them all into one space and so
there's a lot of creative stuff we can
do we have a lot of liberties because of
this whole nexus concept and you know
we're not taking the lower so specific
and so seriously that you can't have
Arthas fighting rain or things like that
so as we make more games it just means
more things to pull from that's why we
literally have this kind of unending
source of heroes and battlegrounds that
we can choose from sorry tying into that
you guys announced I think three
Warcraft universe heroes today also lost
vikings what determines are you know
what what decides were you're pulling
from or what kind of heroes from sharon
lee all the different options it gets
head so there's a lot of things that go
into that um some of it is what we
currently need in the game if maybe we
need another support or we need another
assassin we might lean heavily on that
side the other one is what fans ask for
like for example lost vikings last year
when we were at blizzcon we had a lot of
feedback hey what about lost vikings
what about some of these older games
that you guys used to make and literally
a year later here we are there in the
game so there's a lot of different
things that go into it we also want to
keep a nice representation across the
universe
so if we're getting a little bit to
warcraft heavy we might you know bring
in some more Diablo and starcraft things
like that I just imagine at the blizzard
offices you guys must have like a giant
whiteboard with a bunch of names
scribbled on it from all this different
stuff yep along those lines you guys
just announced overwatch actually feel
like I think the background of the
presentation today had one of the new
heroes from overwatch and it uh what
should we expect from overwatch in terms
of heroes of the storm so we don't have
anything to announce yet but just like
you know the fact that we just got done
talking about how we can pull these
heroes from our other games I would not
be surprised to see overwatch characters
and heroes at some point in the future
very good I actually that about wraps up
all of my questions but I just want to
thank you so much for the interview
anything that players should expect to
see or any big differences as we head
into the closed beta I think you're just
going to see more content more heroes
more battlegrounds more features we
talked about ranked play we talked about
the draft mode coming up we're going to
keep inviting more players we're really
excited to have everyone in this game I
know there's a lot of people who want to
get in it's just growing and growing in
this you can kind of feel the energy
behind him well thank you so much for
the interview thank you everyone else
you can check out the rest of our
coverage of all things blizzcon at
gamespot com
you